good morning and welcome to this
licensing act subcommittee
this subcommittee is called to
consider an application for a new
premises license in respect of old joe's
cafe bistro old joe's golf and leisure
venue at corner tie in sudbury
i understand that the um objector was
uh present but he seems to have dropped
out so he may um if he can get
reconnected we'll we'll bring him back
in um
but all parties that have made an
application or a representation have a
right to to be heard
um at a hearing in accordance with the
hearing regulations of 2005.
and the procedure we will follow
following some preliminary formalities
will be that the
licensing officer will present
a report of the application to the
subcommittee
the applicant will then have an
opportunity to make his representations
in support of his application
then the objector if present will be
able to make his objections known
there will then be
brief summing up by the licensing
officer and then the applicant mr bisek
will have the opportunity to have a
final say before the members go into a
private session to consider the
application and make a decision
after each representation there will be
an opportunity for members and other
attendees at this
hearing to ask questions of that it's
not a time to get into conversations or
to challenge it's just questions for
clarification
and
to make sure that everything is clearly
understood and you want all the points
properly raised
this virtual meeting of the licensing
subcommittee i would like to remind
everyone present that this meeting will
be broadcast live to youtube
and will be capable of repeated viewing
the meeting will be recorded except
where there are confidential or exempt
items
if you make a representation to the
meeting you will be deemed by the
council to have consented to being
recorded by entering this meeting as a
speaker you are also consenting to being
recorded by the council and to the
possible use of those sound recordings
for webcasting and or training purposes
the council members of the public and
the press
may record film photograph or broadcast
this meeting when the public and the
press are not lawfully excluded
please ensure that microphones are muted
when you are not speaking
that you do not interrupt other speakers
that if you are attending meeting to
speak and persistently interrupt the
meeting you may be asked to leave
additionally you will be invited to
speak and ask questions by the chairman
which is
council aires
yes just to declare that
um good morning i'm a favorite district
council as well
my granddaughter esther booth works as a
student um here on maybe saturdays or
during the holidays
but i have no pecuniary interest just to
be open and transparent to say that
esther works there thank you
thank you very much councillors
i also declare that i believe i have met
anna bolton previously probably about
four years ago
at old joe's cafe but it will not
influence any decision that i make this
morning
thank you any other declarations of
interest
no chairman
thank you very much councillor
and i will now ask um everyone to
introduce themselves
i will start
with the introduction of the
subcommittee members my name is margaret
mabry councillor margaret mabry and i am
the chairman of the licensing and
regulatory committee
and i ask
councillor ayers to introduce herself
please
morning everyone and as i said
previously also a baby district
councillor and sudbury town councillor
thank you chair
thank you and councillor carpenter
yes good morning councillor sue
carpendale i'm the vice chairman of this
committee thank you
thank you very much and i now ask
officers in attendance to introduce
themselves and uh if i may i will start
with our legal advisor
yes my name is nigel tallow i'm legal
advisor to this subcommittee
thank you a licensing officer
if you would like to start please
um hi my name is catherine greene i'm
licensing officer for baby mid suffolk
thank you
good morning kay sanders licensing
officer lay the mid topic
thank you
good morning kerry chandler licensing
officer for baby and mid-suffolk
thank you and our governance officer
good morning everyone i'm karen sayer
governance officer
thank you and we have a trainee
governance officer with us this morning
good morning bethany webb trainee
governance officer
thank you thank you very much and you
may also see a photograph of mandy smith
um mandy would you like to introduce
yourself too please
so you may not yes sorry good morning my
name is mandy smith um i'm a governance
officer um and i'm here doing the live
streaming in the background
thank you very much thank you everyone
for introducing themselves
um i would now like to ask the applicant
to introduce themselves and if they are
represented and to also ask the
representative to make their
introduction good morning mr biosit
hi good morning my name is birch baizet
i'm i'm the
business owner
of the
old joe's cafe and bistro
thank you
and also i also the
put a request
to support my application uh
there i i i wanted to add
miss anabolton
and she's at present
thank you thank you very thank you very
much um anna bolton would you just like
to introduce yourself very briefly
sorry yes good morning anna bolton
director of achieving aspirations which
provides the overnight short break
service um known as green acres which is
on the site
of joel joe's
thank you very much thank you
i am now going to ask mr bicept to
confirm that he has received receipt of
the procedure of this meeting the report
and copies of the relevant notices
yes i have
thank you very much um i will just stop
for the moment to see you john hills
thank you for now joining
thank you i'm going to just ask my
governance officer to make sure that mr
hills is with us i believe mr hills has
just joined the meeting chair yes i'm
back on
thank thank you thank you very much and
uh and i'm sorry that you've missed the
first four items
um on the agenda mr dulu do you wish to
repeat anything
um yes i'll just quickly summarize and
just go through the procedure for mr
hill on the hills
yeah we're just going through um
formalities
nigel he's dropped out is he gone again
okay apologies yeah
thank you
i think we we will have to um continue
um uh but we
hopefully mr hills will be able to join
us um at at some time
i now ask whether whether the applicant
or
anyone else wishes to withdraw their
application or representation or are you
continuing mr biceps
yeah i'm continuing thank you very thank
you very much
i now have questions for the licensing
officer
which is have that have there been any
requests from parties for permission to
call witnesses
no chair
thank you very much
have the parties indicated they wish to
present documentary or other material
no chair
thank you very much
um i now ask mr biasit
if you
could estimate the time required to
present your case and to ask questions
of the other parties during this hearing
do you have an estimation of the time
please
well
the
i'm not really familiar with the process
you need to understand you need to put
that into account the
so
i don't apply for licensing
premises licensing every every week or
every month so i don't know the process
so i i assumed uh i put 60 minutes down
on the paperwork however
i just put that down purely i really
don't know the whole process okay
thank you mr pirate city it is um
sometimes a difficult one to estimate
that to them but we appreciate your um
your explanation for that um
uh can i ask anna bolton i'm sorry um
john hills
is now joining
again
but i will continue with anna bolton if
i'm if i may um
i'm sorry i don't know whether you wish
to be addressed by anna bolton or mrs
bolton or ms or however so please inform
me
anna is fine right thank you thank you
very much
um
you are here as a supporter of mr meyer
said um do you have any inclination as
to any timings that you would need
um
no i mean the um
no just
i really don't know
you don't know mr buyer said if um if
anna bolton could just reply and
i i i think uh
how much time it would need is dependent
upon the questions that are asked of me
but in terms of my representation
i don't think i need more than five
minutes okay thank you very much thank
you that's very if i could just if i
could just step in and assist mr buyer
all that's being asked for you is really
to give a statement in support of your
application um it's not a technical
exercise you should be worried about
it's just your opportunity to to present
your application to the members and make
sure that they fully understand um what
you're applying for
i i totally understand but the it is
very difficult for me to uh depends on
the questions and the um
there will be some questions uh during
my statement and uh
that's why i made it very clear uh i put
down as 60 minutes but that would be
very excessive i know and i will try to
cut it down very short
uh depends on the uh
questions yeah questions will be asked
maybe asked at the end of the the
presentation that's fine um so so it's
just you really just just to sort of
i would say i would only the uh submit
few uh
uh photos uh
for you to see
and uh and other than that uh
that will be uh
my personal statement and
the and my personal grievance uh against
the council and apart from that uh
the
i don't know how mr
what i need you to do is just
concentrate on your application if you
have other issues regarding the the way
your application's been dealt with that
needs to be dealt with outside this
subcommittee that the members today are
here purely to consider your application
if you have any other issues and
complaints
that there is a procedure that may be
followed and you'll be encouraged to do
that if you do have issues but i would
ask you for the purposes of this hearing
to concentrate on purely on your
application for the license
i i totally understand i am
concentrating on my application and you
don't need to
actually tell me the uh
the i can't put scriveners in or
complaining during the during the or at
the meeting
which i i can
by my rights however the all i need to
tell you the i have previously
registered few complaints uh against the
process against
certain individuals however i have not
replied i have not received any reply i
mean it's all good you are telling me i
have to follow the art external
processes but if the if the external
process is not
really mr bicep the purpose of this
subcommittee is to consider your
application
it will be in your best interests
to put your application forward to the
subcommittee
to answer any questions that they have
in respect of your application if you
have other issues
i assure you they can be dealt with and
they will be dealt with properly however
this subcommittee is here to consider
the application only
if if you start
talking about other things that are
irrelevant to the application
then i will ask
um
that
you'll be muted so we can continue with
the actual proper deliberations of this
application
okay
i understand does it apply to everyone
um mr buyer said um thank you and mr
dulu thank you thank you very much we
are we are here to um to deliberate on
the your application and we will do that
um
as
is required by baby district council so
thank you could i just ask is mr hills
with us again or not please
he does appear to be chair yes
thank you um mr hills um i i'm chairman
of the licensing and regulatory
committee hello my name is councillor
margaret mabry would you like to
introduce yourself please and then mr de
lou will just
um speak a few words on the process
because we have got to item five on the
agenda
hello i'm john hills thank you very much
mr hills thank you and welcome mr dulu
thank you chair yeah um
just from mr hill's benefit i'll just
quickly go up the procedure again we are
into the the application can i just say
i have been listening to you online
you've been able unable to communicate
so i am aware of what's gone before okay
okay so you know how the process is yeah
i don't know what i would just like to
say in respect of your um your
representations
is that my advice to the the
subcommittee today is that they're going
to treat your representation as one from
an individual
rather than the corner thai residents
association
and the reason for that is where a group
is represented by an individual there is
an expectation that evidence of
authority to represent the group is
provided
if it's an informal group
quite often the other members will
attend
and sit in on the on the hearing
or there will be a document with
signature of other members of that group
to confirm that they are part of that
representation
for a formerly constituted group we
would expect minutes of a meeting to
confirm that the group's representations
um have been
approved and and they are
agreeable to those representations
now this doesn't mean that your
representation should not be considered
an appropriate weight should still be
given to them
but for the purposes of this decision
they are taking your representations as
you from an individual
okay thank you chair
thank you thank you very much mr dulu
we're moving on to item five on the
agenda please which is the hearing
and i'm asking the licensing office
officer catherine green to present their
report b stroke l a
sub sub stroke 2 21 stroke 1 and to
summarize the matter under consideration
catherine green please
thank you chair
this hearing is to determine an
application made for the grant of a new
premises license made under section 17
of the licensing act 2003 by burst and
buyers it in relation to the premises
old joe's cafe and bistro
old joe's golf and leisure center joe's
road corner thai great corner sudbury
co 10 0qb
the application was received by the
licensing authority on the 21st of
september 2021 and a copy of this is
attached to this report as appendix a
the application made has been subject to
the statutory consultation period as
prescribed by regulation the notices
advertising the application have been on
display at the premises and published in
the west suffolk mercury 29th september
2021 edition
full details of the proposed activities
and timings are contained within the
application form attached as appendix a
to this report
the operating schedule steps proposed by
the applicant to promote the four
licensing objectives are listed as part
m of the application form
a hearing is necessary to determine the
application following receipt of
representations which have not been
withdrawn
the subcommittee will be aware that its
consideration is confined to promotion
of the four licensing objectives and the
need or commercial demand for licensed
premises are not considerations for the
licensing authority when discharging its
licensing functions
the licensing authority must carry out
its functions under the act with a view
to promoting the licensing objectives
which are the prevention of crime and
disorder public safety prevention of
public nuisance and the protection of
children from harm
where revisions are made to the
legislation or guidance issued by the
secretary of state there may be a period
of time when the local statement of
licensing policy is inconsistent with
these revisions
in these circumstances the licensing
authority will have regard and give
appropriate weight to the relevant
changes guidance and its own statement
of licensing policy
the subcommittee will also be aware of
human rights act 1998 considerations
specifically article 6 and articles 8
and 1 of protocol 1 when determining
applications for the grant of a new
license
the licensing authority has received no
representations from any of the
responsible authorities under the
licensing act 2003
environmental health as a responsible
authority as the act have undertaken
mediation on their areas of concern and
the applicant has agreed the inclusion
of two conditions attached as appendix d
to this report
there has been two representations
received made by other persons which
includes local residents businesses and
residents associations and these are
attached as appendix c to this report
the subcommittee must have in regard to
the representations made to take such of
the steps below if any as it considers
appropriate for the promotion of the
licensing objectives
to grant the license subject to
conditions which are consistent with the
operating schedule accompanying the
application
modified to such extent as the authority
considers appropriate for promotion of
the licensing objectives and subject to
any mandatory conditions which must be
included in the license
to exclude from the scope of the license
any of the license for activities to
which the application relates
to refuse to specify a person in the
license as premises supervisor or to
reject the application
for these purposes conditions of the
license are modified if any of them are
altered or omitted or any new condition
is added
any party agreed by the decision taking
taken by the licensing authority in
respect of this application has a
statutory right of appeal to the
magistrate's court this concludes my
report chair
thank you very much catherine green for
that
um i now ask if the applicant has any
questions for the licensing officer
please mr bioset
you're currently on mute mister sorry
thank you
yeah it i couldn't hear the can you
please repeat
the question
um i'm asking if you have a question for
the licensing officer from the
from her report no no i can't
thank you very much anna bolton may i
ask you if you have any questions for
the
licensing officer
no
thank you very much mr hills
ah hopefully you're still with us um yes
do you have not playing for you
yes i i do i had um obviously the the
questions i submitted
um previous meeting
um i you are going to have to do
those mr dillon thank you
mr hills is your opportunity to ask
questions of the licensing officer in
respect of the report that she's just
submitted
do you have any questions relating to
that report
um
no i don't think so because i i never
heard the report
it's just been presented did you not
hear what was said
no i i it keeps buffering okay do you do
you have a copy of of the papers
yes i have a copy of the the documents
that have sent me them in front of me
that was the report that was summarized
do you have any questions as to the
actual report
um
no i'll leave it at that at the present
um
thank you very thank you very much mr
hills and thank you mr dulu
um the i'm just going to ask my
subcommittee now if they have any
questions for the licensing officer um
may i ask councillor carpendale first
please uh thank you chairman yes i just
wanted to
check with the licensing officer um have
these premises had
um a license previously under a
different ownership
uh yes councillor it was known as
quentin's cafe but the owner of
quentin's cafe um council and
surrendered the license therefore
this is why mr bias it has to apply
again so so there has been the license
on these premises before
yes and were there any particular issues
reported at that time
i am una where chair of of any
particular issues other than those that
were raised at the original hearing for
the previous license okay thank you
thank you very much councillor ayers
no thank you chair none
um thank you i have none at the moment
thank you very much
um
i now ask um the applicant to present
his case for
granting the license mr bioset if you
are ready please
thank you
thank you thank you very much councillor
the um
yes i i'm the business owner for the uh
august cafe and there
um
it is uh
i i do employ uh four people there per
on permanent basis and uh plus the
casual workers you know and the students
they help us out and
um
and we are
well known for
um the
high standards the quality uh food
served there and the the
the dog friendly environment
um the and we are open to anyone and we
welcome anyone
and we support local businesses so i do
not buy anything from the whole sailors
and
and
we support local butchers uh etc
um
however
the
i was bit i was a bit disappointed the
um when i received the uh
objections uh regarding to my
applications because as
the
licensing uh
the officer the catherine
mentioned there was a previous
license granted for that premise okay
and
the before uh before i applied for this
uh license i i made it very clear to the
licensing department
i am very new to the
[Music]
licensing application
and i just want to copy paste
from the previous grant and fill the
application form and submit it
and
so
under their either under their guidance
the my application uh
we we had some discussions and they
asked me the can i change this to that i
said that's fine no problem and we
we made the changes and they were happy
and they received the applications and
uh they accepted my application and
obviously
then i receive this uh
recommend to refuse or recommend reject
sections uh based on my applications
however as i said to you before
my current application is
very very similar very very similar
to the previous grants previous
application made by mr quentin
in 2019
and he surrendered he surrendered his
application in 2020 just before the
pandemic
so basically in terms of
uh in terms of law in terms of the any
uh there is nothing has been changed and
in fact the
uh all we receive uh here
um
they put more restrictions on my
application which i'm struggling to
understand and i'm quite happy to
cooperate i'm quite happy to compromise
uh which
previously environmental officers
contacted me and they they asked my
uh
they asked me whether i would like to
compromise on few issues i said that's
fine i'm happy to do that you know and
the as you can see on the report it is
mentioned um
which i did it i wish i wish i received
the same from the uh other authorities
uh
if they had any concerns prior to the
decisions made you know that's that's
where my problem is and then i they
i don't know whether you have been to uh
you are you familiar with the old joes
uh
or not have you been there uh any of you
do you know of the area
um can i answer i am councillor reyes
please do
yes um i actually have um uh been there
many times in fact used to play golf
with my husband there and he died in
2002 so i'm going back quite a few years
so yes i'm very aware of the area thank
you thank you i am also very aware
mister
of of the of the area
okay thank you very much i mean the uh i
wanted to share the few photos with you
whether it is possible or not i don't
know but still i have taken some images
i'll just have to come in there um
unless the documents were provided as
part of your representation in
accordance with the application then
then they shouldn't be considered happy
for you to to make uh to just describe
the site
and explain it um but further
documentation shouldn't be accepted at
this stage
well it is it is just photo you know
it's a photo
i mean if you think that is that's not
appropriate then that's fine you know um
okay
let me make it very clear the old joe's
cafe
the nearest residential
the i mean it's very very open area very
big area and it has uh
many green areas attached to it
um you can see on my uh application
there is a place called uh putting green
which is again big green area uh there
are some wooden benches there
uh
the
and also on the right hand side there is
an area called the paddock
which is enclosed uh fenced in area um
and
uh we again uh put a few benches there
uh for people to sit down and enjoy uh
their time at the cafe um so the
in terms of the neighborhood in terms of
the neighborhood
um
the
near
there is a there is a lake there is a
lake after the
all jaws borders the the boundaries
there is a lake between the nearest
resident residential house so
and that is called water edge i believe
and
and the water edge
uh
the residents uh they are the closest to
the uh old joe's cafe and roughly in a
walking distance from the cafe's door uh
by walking roughly 200 yards the array
okay
and then so
uh
and
in the appendix c
uh
appendix c
they have got statement there they
support my application and they don't
have any issues whatsoever
these
this is the household nearest to the
cafe
so
um
when you look at from the cafe again
any areas from the cafe you can't see
any houses whatsoever it's a vast green
area okay
i mean
maybe you can call it as middle of the
nowhere that's the the feeling you get
but um
i was quite surprised all those uh
allegations and accusations and the uh
the incorrect uh
the information uh given
by uh
the
ctra uh i was a bit surprised you know
and i had i had a meeting with the ctra
uh the vice chairman mr hills and a few
weeks ago um
and
i i i was agreed for him
i was agreed to compromise on my
application uh
and if david drove their uh
objection um they
so we left the meeting amicably and uh
next
day unfortunately that didn't uh
materialized um the
yeah i'm a bit disappointed and
i looked at the history of the uh
jaws
road i'm talking about the postcode co
10 0 qb i'm just talking about that
postcode
there was
since 2017 since 2017
there was 25 planning applications has
been submitted
by various
businesses various people okay
so 10 of them
they were belong to all joe's cafe all
jaws golf
range
and the 15
submitted by
the certain uh residents
or the businesses
so
when you look at those 10
the
applications uh planning applications
has been have been submitted to council
uh since 2017 uh by the old joe's
business owner
every single applications
more or less has been
the objected by the ctra okay there are
pages and pages and pages is it
i totally understand they got their
their own reasons to object but
they only objected to all jaws cafes
applications all jaws all joe's golf
driving range applications anything
comes from that area the object but
there was no objection whatsoever
on the rest of the applications which is
nearly 15 applications has been made by
other parties
and the ctra
didn't even make a comment about it
so
again
when you receive the when you receive
the objection letter from the ctra
and you all of you
read that uh letter and can you please
tell me
where i where am i
within that letter where am i it's all
everything is to do with
someone else it is nothing to do with me
i am very very small part of that
okay that's it
thank you for that i think it would
benefit you if you could
um i mean we've seen the objections and
they will be referred to and considered
appropriately i can assure you that
what i think would benefit you is to
give the members now some idea of the
business that you intend to run and give
them a
a good sort of summary of of the kind of
business that that's going to operate on
the site
thank you mr dulu that would be really
useful okay i am the
as i as i said as i said at the
beginning of my uh conversation the uh i
am uh
i'm planning i i am running at the
uh
i am offering a very high quality
service there within our capability okay
and
we support local businesses
and what we intend to do
uh when we get our license
so this is not really uh
this is not a pub this is not a bar
this is just
the part of the golf club
and
the so it's
people who come
there enjoy the maybe
the glass of wine or the uh
bottle of beer so that's all all about
it is not really
it shouldn't take into the consideration
like we are gonna run that place as a
uh
the town pub or the bar or nightclub
whatsoever so we
that that is we are planning to do we
are planning to offer uh
you know
the
drinks with the meals uh if not they can
have they can enjoy sit down there uh
enjoy their drinks and uh uh enjoy the
having a having a good time there um
furthermore they
obviously there will be some events uh
we are hoping because we need to survive
this i'm running a business okay we need
to survive and uh so there will be some
events and even when i said some events
these are obviously weather permitted
events so as we live in britain uh there
is no guarantee for anything is it so
the
uh
so
uh predominantly it will be summertime
the
or possibly uh springtime um
the
so we will have uh
possibly some events booked
so we are planning to
put some
sort of
depends on the planning permission uh
the marquee or the
serving hearts in in that greens you
know green areas i mentioned before and
it will not be on the permanent base so
it will be on the uh
it's not going to be permanent
so um
in terms of the uh music live music
again uh
predominantly it will be indoor uh
during the winter time uh again if we
have any uh
events booked
uh it will be uh
obviously it will be
set up uh
the outdoors
um
and also the uh
i mentioned on my application there will
be
uh special events the
like the
world cups the you know the football or
rugby or whatever you know whenever
whenever the england wales or the
scotland place obviously we would like
to show that to people they can enjoy
the watch the game and
uh have
a
bit fifth drinks and meal
so
um i i i am quite happy i'm quite happy
as i said to ctra
at our previous meeting i'm quite happy
to let
any residents
at all jaws any residents there i'm
quite happy to let them know in advance
right
and there will be events
uh
it will be operated within those hours
okay and it will be uh
it the alcohol will be served and it
will finish serving at this time so i it
will be detailed basically uh
information given to them but um so
that's all i can do and i will take all
uh precautions and all the uh relevant
uh
the concerns uh regarding the
uh
legal implications the
um the like uh it was mentioned on uh on
the report so i'm quite happy to
uh
to take remedy for those recommendations
thank you mr bicep um
is that your
representation
i would like to continue
well i would like to uh obviously find
out whether if there is any questions
from any parties so then i can carry on
if they want me to
thank you thank you mr mr bicep um i'm
i'm going to ask if you would like your
supporter anna bolton to speak now
yes please yeah thank you
anna bolton
good morning again thank you for the
opportunity to speak
um
having listened to two persons and and
having the opportunity to speak to
yourselves i've been sitting here
writing down a few notes and actually
would ask that i just have a probably a
little bit longer than five minutes
because i feel that uh the risk of um
uh
going off tangent it might be quite
useful to give a little bit of
background
information about how we ended up being
on the site um and
what it means to us to be there as a as
a organization and also in providing uh
service for services for some adults
with additional needs can i just stop
you there um
and if i'm if i may and will this be
supporting mr bias it's application
yes that
um i'm quite happy can i ask my fellow
councillors if they are happy for that
to be extended by
more than five minutes councillor ayers
is agreeing yes councillor carpenter yes
yes please carry on anna thank you so
so um i don't i'm sure of your
experiences of working in the learning
disabilities field but i've been doing
it my entire career i started off my
career working in big institutional
hospitals
and have watched a way in which the
communities have embraced people moving
out of the hospitals and into the
being active members of society
so to actually and and generally
speaking all of the premises that i've
operated my services from in the past
have been old rundown buildings that we
make the best of so the opportunity to
be involved in building something brand
new for people with disabilities with a
specific surface uh with a specific
purpose was actually really um something
quite special so a building that we
could be proud of so we were involved
from the start the vision was always
that this was going to be an activity
center as the planning um for it was
consented and for an overnight short
break center now i know it's known as
respite but that's actually very old
language to be using respite care is
about giving people a break from their
caring responsibilities for the people
that come to us we talk about short
breaks because it's about making sure
it's a fun making sure it's a nice
experience for them a mini holiday a bit
like you would take if you're going to
go for a weekend break in a city break
somewhere so and of course the side
effect of that is what we're looking
after those adults with the disabilities
those that are their regular carers are
usually their parents still are getting
some respite their caring
responsibilities so in terms of it being
um a center for people coming along to
have a really nice relaxing time and and
quiet etc as there's an understanding of
that's not necessarily the case it's
about the young people being able to
come or the adults coming in and having
a nice time
so the concept on the site the activity
site is that the young people when they
come they get involved in the golf they
play foot golf they use the cafe um
quite significantly they'll go over
there they'll practice using their money
exchanging things buying things it's a
much bigger center than just actually um
the the respite as it seems to be being
referred to it's actually much more
encompassing and on that basis we would
absolutely support the development of
the cafe to be able to offer other
activities because for actually our
service users in our in the short break
center it means that there is a lot more
available to them on site to enjoy and i
don't know about you but if i'm going
away for a weekend which i am this
weekend i know a glass of wine will be
involved with my meal in the evening it
shouldn't be any different for the
people that are actually accessing our
services if it's within the safety rules
for them which of course we have all the
risk assessments around it they're
adults in their own right if they enjoy
a glass of wine they're entitled to have
one it's not about protecting them from
it's about including them in what is
normal for the rest of us because
they're adults we should be being
inclusive
the second point of this is about
inclusivity um
as i've said all the way through my
career it's been about we've been we i
say we and i include myself in the
learning disability community because
i've worked in it for too long we've
always been the ones that have been
knocking on the door of other places
saying can we be included too can we
come along um and we've often met with
resistance to that by actually having
something and i hold this absolutely
very dear to my heart
if we have got as a community something
that people without disabilities want
they'll come to us
and that by that way we are turning
inclusion absolutely on its head so
people without the disabilities are
going to want to use the center that
we've got and therefore by default we
will have an inclusive service and
that's what we're striving to achieve i
hope as an intel as a company as a as a
community and actually as a nation that
actually we're all on an even footing
and i absolutely support the application
for the licensing because i just think
that takes us one step further to um
supporting our
more marginalized people in society to
have an inclusive meaningful and
enjoyable social life as well as um
promoting other activities and
opportunities for them to learn
and that's really all i've got to say
and thank you anna that um that was most
useful i think i i'm because you have
spoken so passionately
and about the respite center i need to
declare that i am actually
um a special needs tutor
and that i am also a carer but not for
um
young younger adults but um
for someone much older so i do declare
that but thank you
very much for that um i'm now going to
um
ask my subcommittee if they have any
questions and counselor airs does
already so please ask your question
councillor
well thank you very much could you could
you just um describe who who that's for
if it's for mr bison or for anna anna i
can just say anna um asking um the
question about um maybe the type of
disabilities that
um those and people who come to stay are
how they are and i also must declare
that i taught at thomas woolsey school
for years
and i taught the um the fe unit and your
point about them having a drink if they
were over 18
and we would take them away on holiday
they would be allowed to have a drink i
was involved with the bsad
and
again they would drink in a moderate way
and yes they're adults they should be
allowed to be included
and so that's very very important and
the times when i've taken students away
is important for everyone to understand
one mother said to me once i have loved
those four days away because i took them
to stern mandeville because i wasn't
wiping his nose every five minutes or
his bottom
this is what it adds up
you am i can i was there a question
there please
yes times of disability
thank you very much anna would you like
to reply we we actually support um quite
a wide range of disabilities and we have
um in the center itself there is um the
downstairs bedrooms can accommodate
people with very physical disabilities
so we have a hoist overhead hoisting and
specialist equipment to support people
with quite complex
needs the downstairs is actually
equipped so that we can cater for more
than one person with that level of need
because i'm sure if you worked with
thomas woolsey you'll be aware that
there's very few places that can
accommodate two friends with physical
disabilities to go away together so the
point being that we were able to
actually enable that to happen so um you
know groups that are friends with that
level of disability can come and stay
together we also have um
young people come and stay who have who
are quite mobile who have got quite
severe learning disabilities um
cognitively
certainly we have young people come who
are on the autistic spectrum it's i mean
in terms of age they're all over the age
of 18
and
the moment i should think probably are
the oldest that comes is probably
somewhere near the age of 30.
um and um
dave um
the whole rate i mean you know you can't
really say what what type can you
because everybody is so unique in terms
of their support needs so um but yeah a
whole range of disabilities come we're
very happy for you to come and visit us
thank you thank you very much can i just
come back there
and i also share your um how important
it is having asked at loads of pups in
the area
20 mile radius um i only found one that
would accept myself and my students
because of their disabilities to be
careful so i do appreciate that how
important this thank you thank you
councillor um councillor carpenter thank
you chairman um firstly if i could just
ask uh miss bolton uh one or two things
um firstly um
how long has your center been on the
site
we the the center was actually built um
oh gosh during it it only opened in
i want to say spring last year we was we
were due to open in the
just as the pandemic sort of was
starting to hit its peak so
unfortunately that really sort of
obviously delayed things enormously so
we've really only been operational
probably for just over a year now um but
center was actually completed i think
just before the pandemic actually hit
it's hit its worst point so again we we
are very new so a bit like a bit like
burst and we you know we are still um
still opening our doors as a new
business um and welcoming people in the
the difficulty um
sorry going off turns a bit the
difficulty the biggest difficulty moment
as it is in all of the care sector if
you like is is recruitment we've got
lots and lots of uh young adults who are
very very keen to access the center and
develop it but recruitment is really
tough at the moment so we are um you
know we and we employ people in the
local area so we're looking at a
targeted campaign to get get more people
through the door in terms of staffing
are you um expecting that obviously you
will have adequate levels of supervision
to assist
um your guests um when they might want
to use the facilities or go to the cafe
have a have a glass of wine or whatever
absolutely there we
registered with cqc with the care
quality commission um and all of the
service users that attend our services
have a risk assessment around them and
that very much details what level of
support they can have and and and what
activities they can undertake and of
course those are consented to by those
that um might hold parental risk but not
parental responsibility but if they um
you know under the mental health and
capacity act etc best interest decisions
and so on and so we would have all of
that in place and some of the service
users require a one-to-one support some
of them might require two to one to go
out and do various activities others
might be happier to be able to go out in
a small group with one member of staff
supervising a couple of service users
together so it's all very bespoke
thank you that was really just by way of
information for me because clearly you
are not the one here
um if i could ask you mr bursett um a
couple of questions
um
your application um is very clear what
you're asking for um and thank you for
for explaining that your major sporting
events that you'd like to cover could be
things like world cup and rugby union
and so on that's clear
um
i think when we're looking at things
like um halloween and bonfire night we'd
we'd be very specific about dates
wouldn't we um
so that we would know exactly what dates
were being talked about i'm not sure
what you mean by special occasions
because they do seem to be um listed
separately from major sporting events so
what what kind of things did you have in
mind for special occasions
well
thank you very much it's certain it's
not the bonfire and halloween because i
really don't like it anyway okay so
um
the
special events the like birthday parties
okay so the or the
anyone who uh willing to
have
willing to book the uh
cafe or the green area for before
the any golf
or food golf um to have a drink together
with their friends um the
predominantly birthday parties um
or uh could be you know weddings you
know the
depends depends on the capability you
know and we are uh
the
basically we are running a business and
uh
i would like to uh
make it very clear the our special
events they will not
be
running every
uh week of the year or every day of the
week so it will be possibly
uh
10 15 times a year you are talking about
and it can vary between the from from
birthday party to wedding reception or
the
the private dinner to
any golf
parties or
corporate meetings this type of things
so this is the i want to keep the scale
a bit uh
bigger uh so um the
and i'm being very frank and open with
you um and i'm quite happy to uh
notify the uh relevant authorities prior
to any uh events there
okay
i'm sorry mr hills mr dulu which is
coming here and i'm sure he's going to
say exactly what i'm going to say but mr
duluth please carry on yeah firstly mr
hills you will have an opportunity to
ask questions in a moment i just wanted
to
give some advice to the the licensing
committee and perhaps as mr bioset has
indicated earlier that he's not
particularly familiar with the licensing
regime
um it's unlikely that the subcommittee
will will permit the non-standard
timings for the major sporting events
and special events special occasions the
reason for that is that non-standard
timings have to be specified within the
application from the outset that the
subcommittee can grant
section 172 of the licensing act 2003
gives the secretary of state
powers to relax licensing
timings for
special events special occasions world
cups
rugby football
jubilees so some of those occasions
you'll be granted um dispensational or
moratorium on the on the restrictions in
any case
with regard to the other events you're
you've been talking about the birthdays
wedding receptions things like that
it would be more appropriate for you to
apply for temporary event notice for
those occasions the licensing team will
be able to give you plenty of advice on
that
if you feel that it is becoming a
regular thing you may apply for a
variation on your license at a future
date if you want to accommodate those
but but my advice to the the
subcommittee was
would be to in respect of the
non-standard timings to restrict it to
the dates that you specified that that
can be identified
okay yeah thank you very much i'm
willing to do that so
it's a learning curve for me um you need
to uh
thank you very much for the advice and i
will take that
thank you thank you very much that was
the clarification i was looking for
thank you thank um thank you councillor
um and uh
mr dilly you've got in there first but
thank you very much and thank you and
this um
notify
residents in advance of activities
could you explain how that would be what
form that would be please
it will be it will be in writing in
writing thank you very much
um
the i will i'm planning to drop a letter
uh to each uh
household uh
jaws road so they will be notified
and have you um considered that this
time frame that you would give for that
well the
the you need to understand some some
events can be booked a bit on the late
notice so as soon as we have any
bookings made
and uh
the if there obviously if the if the
bookings have been made you know in
advance long time advance then i am
going to put the notice uh
and let them know uh within a week uh
possibly seven days
seven days before the event unless
there's a last minute meeting that last
minute booking i will immediately inform
the neighbors and the relevant
authorities
thank you very much thank you thank you
for that for that clarification
um you also um spoke kindly about
the music
that it will be outdoors in the summer
um and
indoors in the winter
and you've also agreed to our
environmental
officer to restrict the um the noise
levels which
which i'm sure neighbors would
appreciate could you just explain to me
if you did have a complaint about the
noise how we how you would deal with
that please
well the
the
obviously
if there is a
first of all i will make sure the noise
level is not exceeded okay and i will
put relevant the
uh
the
um
[Music]
the
i don't know we can measure the
noise level uh i'm sure we can sort that
out the on the other end
how can i deal with it if the noise
level exceeds uh
the
i will immediately act on it and i'll
get the uh noise level to the level the
necessary level they
adjusted it and
the and corporate with the person who
made the complaint or the whoever comes
to sight uh i will
explain them
the accordingly
thank you that was that was the answer
that um that i was hoping for um you
have um made a submission for serving
alcohol outside in in grassed areas yeah
and have you considered what type of um
drinking vessel that you would use
the cafe cafe is a very small cafe okay
we cannot
possibly serve
uh
pint
from the uh
the kegs you know and then the because
you need you need to have
the storage the seller and you need to
store this and uh so i'm sure
the
uh mr hills wouldn't like to see another
planning application regarding that
regarding to that so that's why we
cannot serve really open points okay
from the uh
the
uh
pull down the vessels but but
um
i
the i am planning to serve alcohol um
the the
from the bottles okay uh and i will uh
open the bottles and the the and
dispense the drink uh
and before i serve the customers
absolutely mister i'm i'm just going to
stop you there because
um i don't we should start um
a two-way conversation uh between you
and mr hills about um serving pints
however um what i'm actually looking for
um and i will ask you this now directly
my concern is um and i think my
colleagues were also slightly concerned
if you're serving drinks in glasses um
i.e
glass
on flattened green or somewhere else if
they accidentally get broken there is
the opportunity for some type of injury
so would you consider polycarbonate
drinking vessels when you are outside
i i would i would i would definitely
consider that that is the yeah that is
the option i you know we we can take uh
the
can i can i tell you about broken
glasses i mean if
they
we are very very clean sights you know
every every spill every broken glass
even in
indoor we take care of it you know and
because my origin is health and safety
as an officer
and so that's why i will i will take all
appropriate
actions
thank you thank you very much um
i just asked my subcommittee are there
any other questions for other uh either
mr biosit at the moment or anna bolton
please no thank you no thank you thank
you very much i'm i'm now going to ask
mr hills
as another the person present um to give
to people his objections mr hills please
sorry church
um mr hills should have an opportunity
to ask questions of mr pisces oh i think
you're pardoned i'm so sorry and i do
apologize
um mr hills would you like to ask a
question
yes i would i do i do actually have one
and a comment
directed towards anna and
um mr bite if i may very short
comments
um
this is a time to ask questions
mr uh hills you'll have your opportunity
to have your say in a moment when you
make your representation but if you okay
okay
that's fine that's fine yeah well the
first one then you in relation to mr
bite and yourselves raising the issue of
the putting green
um and also mr bae mentioning that he uh
cut and pasted the application
um i think you find if you look at the
last application the
the drinking was not allowed in any
other areas but the marquee within the
paddock or within the cafe it was not
allowed outside
thought um because that allowed then
people to revelers or whatever a party
to walk around the whole site
carrying glasses or bottles or was the
hills
are you asking a question yeah
yeah the question is um
really why does he need to justify
people drinking outside adjacent to the
car park
when um when he has a facility and has a
paddock and has a cafe where he can have
the drinking and it won't affect anybody
else because the other provisions are
there for golfers
and for persons residing at the respite
center
um mr bicep would you like to reply well
there is a there is a potting green it
is located between the uh
uh the green acres uh
and us and uh and also the on the uh end
of the putting green uh there are trees
between the car park and the putting
green so basically um the our car park
is nothing to do with the uh putting
green either so there are there are only
a few benches there uh the the near to
cafe and
and they are not permanent benches
because uh
we do we do move them uh regularly and
so we deserve uh we would like to serve
alcohol there and it shouldn't be a
problem and if you serve it if you serve
it as
the
the
the as you uh recommend it uh within the
plastic claw
glasses then the i think i don't
understand the problem you know
thank you so much
from the from sorry from the previous uh
application so
the
the is quite right from the pre previous
application however however the
uh
i made it very clear to the uh
during my application i would like to
add that uh
cutting green to the application thank
you thank you mr mr bias that we we are
actually looking at the application that
is in front of us and not a previous
application mr hills do you have any
other questions for mr meyerset or anna
bolton please at this moment
yeah i have one to to anna
if i may yes
yeah anna um
firstly the villagers have no objection
to um persons with sufficient needs
being on the site
any issues were to do with the fact that
it could you couldn't build a building
there but that's been covered we accept
that and we move forward what we are
concerned is is that some
one it's very difficult for you to make
a judgment on what will happen if mr
basic has or or vanessa raywood the
excitement decides to have parties or
anything on the site because um
you've not been there
um
when these situations have risen because
you
so i'd like to ask you
have you or not experienced
um
an event going on where music is loud
and revelers are walking over the area
since since you've opened and i don't
believe you have
no because it's not allowed to do that
now
thank you thank you very much mr hills
do you have any other question
at this time
um
no the and not other
what i've got to ask at the end anyway
the questions i put forward today thank
you
thank you very much um
thank you very much mr hills um does the
licensing officer have any questions for
mr bioset or anna bolton please
uh no chair thank you thank you very
much um my apologies for
um
for my slight error there um
i am now going to ask mr hills if he
would like to present his case please
and i would ask you
mr hills to be respectful to um to
everyone here thank you
um yeah i certainly would be i have no
reason to suspect if you think i'd do
anything different um
um no the i say basically that the
problem is from historically there has
been issues and there was complaints
made about
events that had happened there
previously
um because the noise does carry and
although it was also mentioned that um
mr bender who has recently moved to the
premises which is the closest which is
probably a bit nearer than 200 yards but
it is a lake between it which is a small
lake and lakes you may or may not know
do amplify sound so the noise is
probably increased for the residents but
again mr bender's quite um a right to to
support uh mr basic we have no problem
with that um but again he has only just
moved in and has never been there to
experience an event being held
um so that's that relates to that
um
the the thing questions i would
obviously like to to ask um if i may
i'll i'll start now
um this is a time to present your case
and mr hills
okay okay i'll do that um thank you well
actually yes you know i i am there
representing the the villagers and
historically there has been a lot of
problems with the site and that's why
there has been objections um we in
principle
do not have a problem
with this being a licensed premises
that's not the issue the issue for us is
to have licenses which allow
drinking
totally into unsociable hours like the
late night refreshment license seems to
be no justification when mr basic did
say to me while we had a conversation
that although
he could have them licenses and he could
operate late
that he wasn't going to well from our
perspective you know if if he is
pressured at any time by anybody to to
to have an event or it looks like a good
earner shall we say then mr basic would
want it well if there's no limitations
to the licensing hours specific
licensing hours then
um
it's a free-for-all you can have any
type of event any size of event at any
time
which obviously cause causes problems um
on top of that in relation to
the
respite center
um it is a response it was put in as a
respite center that was on the planning
application and
we do have people who do care for others
who live in the village or or care for
people out of the village and it's it's
known that a lack of sleep for people
and especially people who have um
mental mental or physical difficulties
or problems that loud music played into
the night will restrict their sleeping
whether they like it or not
and
that could cause further problems so
what we're after is that the site
is used
bearing in mind it's a gulf site and the
gulf is a quiet sport um
the the activities that go on there do
not negatively impact on people
near the site and so what we're asking
of
the offices and that is that you you do
place restrictions
on and limitations on the times
and then also we have to raise the issue
that this site this cafe has never ever
had plenty of permission to be a cafe
for anybody to walk on site it was
initially put there
in um to aid golfers when they finished
there was a little drink they could come
and have something to eat before they go
home or previous to the game
the situation now is that there's been
various advertising and that around the
area
and
that's been drawing people in from all
different places to come and get
takeaways or just go there for a meal to
drink and leave which is increasing the
traffic flow and as the location some of
your room fellow officers know
jones road is a single track road it's
unlit it's not maintained very well curb
eating is a go there's potholes and
there isn't sufficient room for two cars
to pass each other
um unless people mount
villages front greens and driveways and
so it's not just one thing it's several
things which are affecting it and
it's it's just not a suitable site to
potentially have parties which
there is no limitation to under the
under the weight the licenses that were
applied for basically events and drink
and food could be sold for 23 and a half
hours a day and i think you'll find that
that's not suitable
thank you mr hills have you have you
completed
yeah i think that's fine until i asked
my questions thank you thank you very
much mr hills i will just point out to
you that um planning permission is a
completely separate item
to um the granting of a license that has
to be i'm aware of that by the planning
committee um thank you very much um if i
may i have a couple of questions for you
um to start off with if i may
yeah
the my first question is you commented
on noise issues that you've had previous
noise issues could you explain those
very briefly please
yes
strangely enough the last time the site
got a license um
uh missed from mr quinton
it was i believe that very morning
uh on a friday i'm sure it was and i may
have been the saturday the next day that
the license was granted they held an
event they had a live band and music was
excessive
villages 500 yards away you could hear
the music i could hear the music and i'm
five or six hundred yards away and
one of the local residents went to the
site and spoke to the licensee and said
you know the music far too loud could
you turn it down he was then verbally
abused by members of their site people
who own the site and people running the
cafe verbally abused threatened
and when he said well can you turn that
music down the mr clinton at the time
which is obviously nothing to do with
this
said oh we can't the band won't let us
turn the music down
um but of course who was there to tell
you phone up the council in the middle
of the night there's nobody there you'd
call the police and they have enough
problems without worrying about noise
issues and so nobody comes
the event's over and it's a case of old
accept it and you know we can't have
this going forward can't blanch to do
anything at any time
thank you thank you mr mr hills um
uh for that for the explanation i'm sure
you have seen within the submission pack
that there has been a restriction put on
by um the
licensing um committee
sorry the i beg your pardon i will
rewind we are the licensing committee
there has been a restriction um
or a condition put forward and been
accepted by the environmental health
officer yeah and
yeah i did see that um i was somewhat
surprised i mean it's
it it's
it's not very closed is it it's not it's
not
it's an open statement that uh could
could easily be abused
well that that is um that is your
opinion um mr hills at the moment i
can't comment on that
um
you
also um
spoke about restrictions on site i've
written that down but
we were talking about yeah yeah in
relation to where
alcohol could be consumed um because it
is a big sight and i don't know how mr
gazette could actually physically stop
people who are at a party event in a
marquee which they can just walk out of
or in a tent or whatever it is and walk
around the site um which could be to the
annoyance and um to persons in the
restaurant center
but it could also be annoyance to if you
just if you walk up the golf course a
little bit there is a lifted building
there um
and uh
so that that's the issue that it should
the drinking should be restricted to in
the cafe
or in or under
any cover that's in the paddock it
shouldn't be anywhere else on the site
um
thank you for for explaining uh mr hills
um we have had a detailed map i'm sure
you've seen it it's also in the pack
which actually denotes where alcohol is
to be
or is being considered to be allowed
so she's on the putting green isn't it
and it's it's um
there is a detailed map um it is for the
patio the putting green the cafe and um
the paddock green so i hope you could
understand the difference in my
um accent for those two
um obvious obviously and and i will
speak so mr bicep can hear this as well
um obviously if there were if this we
were minded to grant this and there was
any
alteration to this then um obviously the
license would have to be um reviewed so
i'll make that quite clear
um i am now going to um
i'm now going to ask
other per other people present here if
they have any um any questions
for you so first of all i'm going to ask
my subcommittee our counselor airs
you've popped up first please
you're right mr hills chair um yes mr
hills um i listen very carefully to what
you said i'm i'm just interested about
your your committee and and your
chairman and
how many people are involved in this
committee please
the committee has
to six members but
obviously each time we have a meeting
um we do
open it up to anybody else in which it
comes along we have an agm normally in a
normal agm yearly but unfortunately
because of the uh restrictions of covid
we didn't hold one last year
and in relation to um
members of the committee we have i think
it's probably 35 35 homes and we
probably have about 33 of them that
pay a yearly subscription and
a couple of others that people that
don't want to be involved in anything
yeah thank you mr hughes um
uh mr dulu wanted to come in there
please was that to stop yeah i just
wanted to come in on on that um as i
stated earlier because we don't have any
actual evidence that mr hills you know
for us to represent
the uh the community association we are
considering his representations as an
individual
thank you yeah i i i know that it was
mentioned to me at this this earlier
this morning um i was just um
a bit surprised that this was never
mentioned to us before because i could
reproduce the letter minutes of a
meeting or anything else thank you miss
thank you mr hills um councillor
carpendale
thank you chairman uh good morning mr
hills um i was going to ask you about um
noise complaints and and who who they've
been made to but you've you've answered
that and if they weren't dealt with
in a satisfactory manner that's
something that we'll perhaps take up out
of meeting
um i you also mentioned something about
possibility of
licensed drinking for 23 and a half
hours
you have the papers in front of you i
wonder if you could just point me to
uh the source of that that um
that argument
oh well a late night refreshment license
as you're aware
last starts i believe at 11 pm to 7 a.m
um persons arrive on site um
7 30. i think mr bizet said he would get
there about 7 30 something like that in
the morning
and uh obviously with these
special occasions license that he was
asking for which is any event
for any reason really um
put on to the normal licensing hours i
think or the opening hours of the site
it was possible
to um to get 23 and a half hours of
occupation of the site and consequently
consumption sale and consumption of
alcohol and food
i wonder if mr de lou could just refresh
our memories
yeah yes the sale of alcohol during this
only um as the application stands the
the late night refreshment
request is between
11 pm and midnight
and that is only in respect of the
non-standard timings
um and i presume that's only required
because you only need late night
profession after that time
and that would be the only time on those
non-standard days
that the premises are likely to be open
so yeah just for confirmation it's for
those sundays before bank holidays
halloween 31st of october bonfire night
the 5th of november and the 24th and
31st of december
and that is from 11 p.m to midnight only
and
what are the differences between the
sale of alcohol and late night
refreshment
the the sale of alcohol is requested um
monday to saturday to uh 10 30 p.m
and on sundays to 9 p.m and the
non-standard timings are again
the same dates as before till midnight
and late night refreshments consist of
what
late night refreshment is hot food
so it's not we're not talking about
alcohol
no the um
there will be alcohol but that's um
under the sound of alcohol request um
and as i said that's normally till 10 30
at night monday to saturday
9 00 p.m on sundays but for the
non-standard timings that will also be
till midnight
thank you
thank you thank you very much
is it worth mentioning obviously we said
before that the the opening hours for
the actual site
are up to 20 30 hours so any consumption
or sale of alcohol after that would
actually be breaching a planning
condition
i appreciate you are not not a lot you
know that's why
mr hill might just
ask you just to be a little more
respectful of the committee thank you um
um
as i have explained to you before the um
planning application is completely
separate to the licensing we've had the
hours um discussed
by mr dulu or confirmed of what the
actual hours for the selling of alcohol
will be and the hours for the um hot
food
so thank you and
members are the committee members are
there any other questions from you
otherwise i'll ask
no thank you mr buyer said do you have a
question for mr hills on his
presentation please
and you're on mute oh better thank you
no no i don't i don't have any questions
thank you can i ask um anna bolton if
she has a question for mr hills
um no i don't think so thank you
thank you thank you very much
and uh the licensing officer catherine
green do you have a question for mr
hills
uh no chair
thank you very much thank you
and we now move on with the with the
hearing and i'm going to move to closing
submissions
and i'm going to ask the licensing
officer to give a closing statement to
summarize any points which need clarity
please
uh thank you chair i am i don't have any
further points of clarification um and
i'll leave the matter there
thank you very much thank you
um and now mr meyer said um
would you would you like to give a
closing statement
um
just very briefly um i am quite happy to
the
compromise and any advice given i will
take that advice and
and i will communicate with the
neighborhoods and i will communicate
with the local authorities
um
so that's all i can say
thank you very much thank you um anna
bolton do you have anything to say
i'd just like to finalize by saying that
i actually think the extension of the
opportunity to have um the license
agreed um and other events and things
being able to happen on site can only
enhance the um experiences of the people
staying in that harsh lake center as
opposed to
beach today detriment
thank you thank you very much i'm just
i'm going to um speak to mr de lou
and are you happy that everyone has had
the opportunity to speak before i move
on
yes chair we appear to have completed
the process thank you very much thank
you
um
now all parties have had
time to put forward their case i now
have to read um a statement to you
on the basis that the subcommittee
considers that the public interest in
excluding the public outweighs the
public interest in its deliberation
being held in public it is it resolved
that
under section
one double zero a
in brackets four
of the local government act 1972
the public be excluded from the meeting
for this item on the ground that it
involves the likely disclosure of exempt
information as defined in part one of
schedule 12 of the act on the ground set
out in regulation 14 in brackets 2 of
the licensing act 2003 in brackets
hearings regulations 2005.
and if i have um a second uh for that
motion please
thank you that's councillor carpental
has second that and to vote please
thank you very much
um i now ask mandy smith to um
to stop the live streaming please
okay thank you everybody for for waiting
the subcommittee has considered this
matter very carefully and have
considered all the representations both
written and and verbal
before them today
consideration was also given to the
council's licensing policy
and in particular to paragraph four
which relates to the relationship with
the planning process
and that confirms that licensing
decisions should be made on
consideration of the
licensing objectives and previous
planning consents are not relevant
however it should be noted by the
applicants that there are requirements
to ensure compliance with the planning
law and make sure you have the the right
planning consents in place as well as
the the licensing consent
and to ensure that you're not in breach
of that legislation
having said that the subcommittee is
satisfied that the granting of a license
will not adversely affect any of the
licensing objectives and that is
therefore determined to grant the
application modified to the extent as
follows
the hours requested for the opening
hours sale of alcohol the live recorded
music and for anything of similar to
that description
and the late night refreshments are all
granted
the major sporting events and the
special occasions cannot be given as a
non-standard timing without being clear
as to when those events will occur as
set out earlier section 172 of the
licensing act um gives the secretary of
state powers to relax those licensing
hours and for other special occasions um
it would be more appropriate for a
request for temporary event notices to
be made or for future modification of
the license
the following additional conditions are
also applied to the license
firstly the two conditions at appendix d
which were agreed with the senior
environmental protection officer
relating to the sound from events
a condition that written notice of
outdoor live music events will be given
to residents in the vicinity of the
licensed premises at the earliest
opportunity
regular checks to be undertaken of the
outside drinking areas
in order to remove any empty glasses
bottles or any open or any broken glass
in those areas
and
when holding events
under the
under the subject of events of a similar
nature to live and recorded music to
consult with the licensing authority to
confirm the proposed events will fall
within that definition
that
condition was added because under the on
your application form you don't actually
specify that the type of events you
propose so it was felt that the
inclusion of this condition
would
give the the license and authority
comforts that you are remaining within
that definition
party or the applicant or any party
who's made representations
to this um
subcommittee today has a right of appeal
if they are not satisfied with the the
decision or any condition that's been
imposed
appeals can be made inviting to the
magistrates court and should be made
within 21 days of receiving the written
notification of this decision
thank you back to you chair
thank you very much uh mr dulu and
before i close close this meeting i
would like to thank everyone um present
for attending um the subcommittee the
members of the public um and all the
officers um i do thank you for attending
i would just like to say to
mr um
bioset
that
you do need to consider that
a requirement is for a designated pres
premises supervisor and your own
personal license still
for the premises and i'm sure that the
licensing team will be able to assist
you with this
i would also like to add that
we do hope
that the line of communications between
yourself and residents will be kept open
for future
um
suitability within the area and we do we
do actually wish everyone well within
the old joe's um vicinity so
thank you again for attending and um
it's goodbye from us thank you
thank you very much